Tout le monde,
rêve de posséder un sabre laser
on pourrait couper son steak avec de la lumière
mais mes rêves de combat épiques ont bien vite été brisées
la première fois que le prof sciences m'a présenté un laser.
Voilà c'est juste de la lumière, à pas mettre dans les yeux
pas de "voum, voum", pas de lame surpuissante,
pas de bras trenché et carbonisés.
Ouais les star wars aime vraiment faire ça
malheureusement un laser ne peut pas devenir une épée,
à moins que il y a eu énormément d'innovation dans le laser,
découpe laser, lecteur de CD, fibre optique, chirurgie, testons ça!
pourquoi on ne peut pas transformer un laser en lames
Bon alors déjà,
un sabre laser c'est composés de quoi?
dans la poignée du sabre on trouve une batterie au diatome qui alimente deux cristaux kyber,
ils vont concentrer l'énergie rayon laser rouge ou bleu vert violet selon la nature du cristal.
mais comme tu t'en doutes
pas de diatome ou de cristaux kyber dans notre galaxie. Sauf qu'en vrai c'est pas non plus un délire surréaliste.
Tu vois ce pointeur laser?
devine de quoi il se compose?
Oui oui une batterie et un cristal.
pour les pointes de rouge il s'agit souvent d'un rubis mais t'affole pas tu vas pas devenir riche en démontant des porteurs laser,
c'est des rubis synthétique!
la batterie du laser produit un courant électrique et qui stimulent les atomes du rubis
et quand leurs électrons sont bien excités ils lâchent la sauce,
ils vont émettre des photons des petites particules de lumière,
qui vont à leur tour percutée d'autres atomes et les stimuler.
Comme les photons sont figés entre deux miroirs,
ils vont faire pleins d'aller retour à travers le rubis
la réaction en chaîne se produit à chaque collision photons, atome.
Le faisceau va être amplifié d'où son nom:
light amplification by stimulated emission of radiation.
Oui oui c'est la vraie signification du mot "LASER".
j'espère vous avoir appris un truc là.
La lumière qui ressort par le petit trou va être super particulière
puisque déjà le rayon ne se disperse pas il reste une simple et fine ligne.
tous les photons vibre de la même façon comme des petits soldats qui marchent au pas cadencé.
C'est pourquoi le laser peut être aussi puissant et à une couleur si intense.
Tu veux changer cette teinte
pas de problème il suffit de prendre un autre cristal ou même de remplacer par un autre gaz,
mais bon je te vois venir,
un pointeur laser ça ressemble pas trop à une arme.
Bah oui,
et heureusement que quand tu veux montrer un truc sur ton diapos tu découpes pas le mur en même temps!
quoique fais gaffe!
Si tu te prends un laser dans les yeux pendant quelques secondes,
le rayon reste assez concentré pour te cramer la rétine.
Un combat jedi,
ça pourrait ressembler à des mecs qui essaye de se foutre un pointeur laser dans les yeux.
Tout de suite mon style
mais voilà on peut quand même faire des lasers beaucoup plus puissant.
Dans l'industrie, coupé du métal avec un laser c'est pas du tout un truc de jedi c'est même la routine
la france est sacrément balèze dans le domaine d'ailleurs car
près de paris il y a apollon l'un des lasers les plus puissants du monde.
Il peut générer pendant quelques femtoseconde,
l'équivalent d'un million de centrales nucléaires.
L'étoile noire n'a qu'à bien se tenir.
On se sert d'apollon pour étudier l'atmosphère terrestre
mais ne pourrait-on pas s'en servir pour la guerre? Pendant la guerre froide
Pendant la guerre froide
on avait lancé un programme appelé star wars,
il s'agissait de méga-lasers destinés à cramer les satellites et missiles nucléaires soviétiques.
Avant qu'il réussisse à atteindre leur cible.
une sorte d'ancêtre du blaster quoi,
sauf que bah voilà on va pas se mentir,
il y a deux trois petits problèmes à régler avant de pouvoir faire le con avec un sabre laser.
Déjà à ses rayons lumineux méga puissant c'est sympa deux secondes,
mais c'est pas avec deux piles que tu as les alimenter.
En fait pour faire fondre une porte blindée en acier comme Qui-Gon Jinn
il faut que le laser maintiennent une température de moins 1500 degrés soit une puissance de l'ordre du giga watts!
Autant que produit à réacteurs à fission nucléaire
et c'est pas très pratique à transporter...
bon au pire disons que pour l'instant on branche le sabre avec un long fil électrique.
Mais il va quand même rester un problème.
Comme on l'a dit le faisceau laser se propage en ligne droite
ça veut dire que tant qu'il rencontre rien il continue,
donc ton sabre laser à une longueur infini.
Ainsi évite de l'utiliser dans ta chambre si tu tiens réellement à ton plafond.
Mais d'ailleurs tu t'es jamais demandé où atterrissent et les tirs de blaster
qui dérivent dans l'espace à la vitesse de la lumière?
C'est quand même vachement dangereux nan?!
Ah oui et dernière chose,
t'as sûrement remarqué en jouant avec une lampe poche que la lumière ça faisait pas "voum, voum"
d'ailleurs en vrai tu peux même pas collisionner la lumière.
deux laser qui se croisent ça fait pas de choc
bon alors si on part sur l'idée de faire un sabre laser on a une centrale nucléaire
sur roulettes pour te suivre partout le sabre c'est plutôt un gros pointeur laser
et ça crame tous super!!
Surtout que pour te battre
il suffirait d'avoir un miroir,
ça te renverrait le rayon laser au plein dessus non on a besoin d'une autre piste..
Un nouvel espoir.
Tu l'as compris le truc qui coince c'est que la lumière n'est pas une matière,
on ne peut pas la toucher, enfin pour l'instant
parce que en 2018 des chercheurs du M.I.T ont réalisé un vieux rêve de physicien.
ils ont réussi à créer des molécules de lumière!
tu vois les photons ces particules fantômes qui composent la matière?
Bah d'habitude quand deux rayons lumineux se croisent
les photons n'interagissent pas entre eux ils s'ignorent royalement.
Bah oui la lumière ça n'existe pas dans tous les sens.
Eh ben les chercheurs ont réussi à forcer les photons à s'associer pour former des molécules!
on peut donc se permettre d'envisager une sorte de chimie de la lumière,
et d'espérer qu'un jour on pourra fabriquer de la lumière en poudre ou en brique ou en sabre laser
après pour l'instant ça nécessite une température proche du zéro absolu,
et les plus grosses molécules photonique,
compte au maximum trois photons alors qu'il en faudrait des billions pour un sabre laser!
Donc on fait quoi?
Moi j'ai pas envie d'attendre d'être aussi vieux que maître yoda pour commencer à jouer au jedi.
pour les plus pressés,
il se pourrait qu'il existe une autre solution.
Et si depuis le début on était parti dans la mauvaise direction?
Parce qu'on s'est dit un sabre laser ça doit marcher avec un laser.
mais pas du tout!
Il existe un état de la matière exotiques de la matière,
qui pourrait ressembler de ouf à une arme jedi.
Tout le monde connaît les trois états classique de la matière:
solide, liquide et gazeuse mais il en existe d'autres dont le plasma!
Dans un atome il ya des électrons qui orbitent autour d'un noyau
et bien le plasma ici chaud que ces électrons sortent de leur orbite
ça donne un état énergétique qui peut couper
n'importe quoi!
la foudre par exemple est un plasma,
et devine quoi piéger un plasma ultra chaud pour produire de l'énergie
c'est exactement le principe de la fusion nucléaire.
Attention on parle pas de fission nucléaire
ça c'est ce qu'on fait aujourd'hui dans les centrales.
Là on parle de fusion sans entrer dans les détails ce serait le graal de la production énergétique
quasiment propre et inépuisable.
C'est la source d'énergie du soleil.
On n'arrive pas encore à récupérer assez d'électricité, mais on étudie dans les  réacteurs expérimentaux
les tokamaks sorte de donuts dans lesquelles le plasma est confiné en lévitation.
Ben ouais on est obligé de le maintenir en suspension parce que tu l'imagines bien,
que sinon il ferait fondre le réacteur
ce secteur vraiment prometteur et dernièrement en pleine effervescence!
d'ailleurs n'hésitez pas à demander en commentaires si vous voulez une vidéo sur la fusion nucléaire.
Et le fait qu'il y ait plein de recherche là dessus c'est très bon signe pour notre rêve de sabre laser.
ça voudrait dire que dans quelques années on si connaîtra assez en plasma pour en faire n'importe quoi!
Ouais ok cool.
mais est ce que le plasma c'est assez puissant pour découper des trucs?
Oh oui!
et on ne s'en sert déjà,
par exemple on fait des scalpels à plasma hyper précis pour les chirurgiens.
Coupé du métal avec?
tranquille!
Et encore mieux,
si deux sabres plasmique se rencontrent les champs magnétiques qui leur donne leur forme vont interagir et se repousser
de quoi avoir un vrai duel et on pourrait même renvoyer les tirs des stormtroopers!
Cerise sur le gâteau,
en changeant la nature du gaz de départ on change la couleur de son plasma,
et la lame aura l'allures d'un croisement entre la foudre
et le soleil niveau crépitements et "voum, voum".
là tu es servi!
Elle aura un style très Kylo Ren avec ses petites étincelles tout ça tout ça quoi.
je sais pas toi mais moi je trouve ça méchamment stylé.
Bon reste quand même le problème énergétique
mais le truc cool avec le plasma sait qu'il peut réutiliser une partie de son énergie pour s'auto entretenir.
Comme un feu, une fois que tu l'as allumé il continue à brûler.
Regarde le soleil en gros c'est une méga boules de plasma.
Bah il est pas près de s'éteindre parce qu'il lui même sa propre source d'énergie!
C'est pas classe non?
Mais attention je suis l'imaginent
allumé un soleil ça demande une quantité colossale d'énergie,
alors démarrer ton sabre, ça paraît dur d'y arriver avec une batterie de la taille d'un manche qu'on voit dans les films.
Là encore les scientifiques ont un dernier atout dans leur poche et celui là il semble vraiment tout droit sorti d'un film
ce petit bijou c'est l'antimatière!!
Si si c'est bien réel
chaque particule possède son antimatière une sorte de jumeaux maléfiques
quand la matière rencontre l'antimatière elle se désintègre mutuellement,
et leurs masses est intégralement convertie en énergie,
c'est l'équation bien connu E=MC2.
Et cette réaction est un milliard de fois plus puissante qu'une réaction nucléaire,
s'est littéralement la forme de stockage d'énergie la plus compacte de l'univers!!
Si là maintenant, tu lâchais un gramme d'antimatière sur le sol ça produirait l'équivalent d'une explosion nucléaire!
Donc évitent s'il te plaît.
En fait une pincée d'antimatière suffirait à alimenter un sabre laser pendant plusieurs vies!
Ouais mais tu vas me dire c'est forcément trop beau
personne ne s'est fabriqué dans l'antimatière ça se saurait quand même.
Et ben si en fait depuis 2006 la nasa cherche à contrôler et l'antimatière,
et le CERN a finalement réussi à fabriquer un nanogramme d'antimatière.
Mais pour la stocker à l'abri de tout contact on doit la faire léviter sous vide dans un champ magnétique...
Sauf que bah il est là le problème ça coûte 45 mille milliards le gramme!!
en fait l'antimatière et la substance la plus chère au monde largement devant l'or et le diamant
mais bon qu'est ce que des tristes billets quand on peut posséder un sabre laser
au final même si on s'est basé sur beaucoup de suppositions,
toutes les technologies, tous les savoirs sont déjà là pour créer un sabre laser.
Mais alors pourquoi aucun ingénieur s'est dit,
je vais en fabriquer un.
Peut-être parce que c'est pas une très bonne idée.
Combattre au sabre laser ça serait hyper gore.
imagine t'es dans son labo tu as réussi à fabriquer un sabre laser
tu t'approches de ta création tu la prend en main et fébrilement tu appuies sur l'interrupteur.
Et que tu crames instantanément.
Mais qu'est ce que tu as cru, tu te serai pas un petit peu enflammé.
Pendant que tu te tord de douleur dans les flammes, tu as une petite pensée pour jeanne d'arc
Jeanne, au secours!!
Et aussi à quel point tu es tu es stupide
qu'est ce que tu fous avec ça dans les mains?
Bah oui chaque objet diffuse un peu de sa chaleur par un rayonnement
quand tu fais du feu t'as pas besoin de toucher les flammes pour sentir la chaleur.
Et dans le cas de ton sable ce rayonnement c'est un sacré paquet d'UV
alors même à distance respectable,
oublie pas tes lunettes et à crème solaire,
et si tu veux te tenir à un mètre c'est chaud.
va falloir de sacrés protection est pas du genre de truc que porte un jedi,
à moins que des gants épais, un masque de soudeur, hummm, tout s'explique
et les autres comment ils font?
Bah ça ça doit être sûrement grâce à la force donc
prévoit de t'acheter un beau chot midichlorien en passant à la pharmacie.
Alors ok, faisons comme si le rayonnement ça n'existait pas.
On va dire tu as une combinaison t'allume ton sabre tu va vouloir découper un mec
ça devrait bien se passer normalement vu que ça coupe déjà du métal.
Bah en fait il se pourrait que ce soit un peu trop chaud,
ton corps est composé de beaucoup d'eau,
et quand on sabre va rentrer en contact avec "tchhhhhh".
Ouai, méga jets de vapeur.
Et quand l'eau passe à l'état gazeux son volume est multiplié par mille!!
c'est à dire qu'en découpant ton adversaire,
s'est énormes quantités de gaz va être éjecté super vite hors de sa blessure.
Dans le jargon, on appelle ça une explosion vapeur
ça va être un carnage de sang et de boyaux, on sera pas vraiment dans l' arme de précision du futur.
le pire c'est que Han Solo reste en contact avec plus de 15 secondes.
C'est suffisant pour vaporiser la moitié de son corps.
Morale de l'histoire,
si un jour quelqu'un te menace avec un sabre laser
prend un verre d'eau et jette lui plus dessus, le mec se fera brûlé par une explosion de vapeur.
Tu peux même approché un gros aimant,
et bah de rediriger le rayon vers lui.
Vous l'aurez compris fabrique un sabre laser,
c'est chaud, et comme on l'a vu la science trouve quand même moyen de repousser inlassablement les limites.
bon avec des conséquences pas toujours attendus.
J'espère que scientifiquement vous avez pu apprendre des trucs
c'était cool de partir d'un exemple rigolo pour apprendre des choses.
Si ce genre de format vous plaît,
s'il vous plaît, abonnez-vous à la chaîne,
on vient juste de commencer sur science trash
Merci d'être toujours plus nombreux,
merci aux monteurs le sang de nous avoir aidés sur cette vidéo.
ditent moi en commentaire qu'est ce que vous feriez avec un sabre laser,
je suis sûr que vous aurez pas mal d'imagination.
on se revoit la semaine prochaine,
allez les amis!!!
Ciao!!
(musique)